guys what's up I'm here with the man
that Don the goat the rush assembler at
the Russian rubber you got your
prospective I like for me cuz it's my
natural state cuz I'm optimistic and
positive I love to compliment people if
it's authentic like if I genuinely think
you're purple here is rad then I'll be
like your hair is [ __ ] amazing I
would never do it if I knew who you were
and I wanted to get to be your friend I
wouldn't say it I genuinely believe that
intent rules the world that if you're
doing it for the right reason you win
I'd rather say something about your
jacket or your sneakers or or just say
hello but what my favorite thing is is
if there's something that I want to
complement something on because it just
starts the vibes so nice it's also
really a compliment for a very
interesting indicator to the other
person most fascinating how people
respond to them guys what's up I'm here
with the man did on the goat the Russian
assembler but the Russian ruble owner
the best of all those I first before
most yes you got a new shoe that's
shopping yes the original height beasts
themselves I mean hold on and I love
that you're wearing it right up your
foot beautiful I mean dark clouds we did
we put out a shoe with k-swiss that was
our third one with them called clouds
and dirt which is basically my thesis in
life which is macro micro the have
ambitions but you have to you have to
put in work to do that right like you
know everything matters nothing matters
just I'm a very I'm a contradiction and
within that contradiction and a lot of
people hit me up they're like you're a
stoic I'm like what is that I google
them like oh maybe maybe I am like I was
like what what I know I am is happy and
I'm happy because I keep things in
perspective and keeping things in
perspective I just tweeted something
that said there's a very fine line
between perseverance and delusion and
it's this question of people always ask
me like when should I give up Gary I've
been doing this you know wrapping thing
I've been doing this vlog doing this
restaurant it's not going well two and a
half years in and I can never answer it
because you need to know the nuances and
details sure but there is an incredible
inflection point in everybody's life
speaking about your early childhood like
acting the amount of people that
literally were like one more audition
this isn't working for me one more
audition and that's the one or one more
song one more album one more startup one
more day at their job there's a one more
try to ask this boy out there's all
these things of like when is it too much
and you just waste your life and you go
into depression or when was it perfect
contradictions I'm fascinated by them
but I'm always on the optimistic side of
them mainly because when it doesn't work
out my big thing is well you now know
what doesn't work you now know you
aren't a rapper and good news you're 31
just you have your whole life as what's
amazing is when you're 43 like I am and
truly you know grew up in Jersey and
went to like Mount Ida College which is
super minority and hip-hop nation at its
finest you hip-hop was so new you know
these 12 year olds these 19 year olds
think of it the way I thought about rock
and roll you know not that I was so all
the way in it but if you're 43 like I
remember like what like the like wearing
adidas with no you know laces was like
something I lived through I you know and
we have a lot of diversity in Edison New
Jersey so you know we were young and
when yo MTV raps came but when then you
go all the way to something that there's
a 25th University of wudang which
already to me was like I was already in
it at that point that was like the firt
that's not sugar hail gangly yeah that's
like there was already mature hip-hop
that that album is 25 years old that's
probably how the generation above me
felt about the Rolling Stones being old
you know and to me the fact that wu-tang
sits on a pedestal like The Beatles and
Rolling Stones that's just weird there's
something you know I'm a Russian
immigrant I was born in the former
Soviet Union I grew up in Queens in a
studio apartment the size of the office
I'm in right now which is at a fancy
building looking at Madison Square
Garden like
my association with the game and what
the game can do for you entrepreneurship
the reason I associate so much with this
whole genre is there's so much
entrepreneurship in it
I love rappers and athletes because what
they're doing when they're 13 and they
love the game what people don't
understand about a hip-hop artist is
that he and she especially the ones I
grew up with they were slinging tapes
from the back of their car in the hood
let or in you know or took the train
into you know Times Square to like trick
the masses here take my day you know
that's me that's baseball cards that's
bubblegum I knew right away that they
were me and I was them meaning they were
just using hip-hop to teach philosophy
and I knew in the same way that you're
watching me do it right now is a 43 year
old white dude I knew that the kids that
they were gonna get to we're gonna get
tricked into getting more thoughtful the
man I'm really gusto I'm like Rick the
end I knew what RZA and [ __ ] meth and
Ghostface and all those [ __ ] were
doing I'm like these [ __ ] are
gonna treat kids and trick-trick kids in
the hood to be successful in life under
the guise of hip-hop because I
understood it from the second I heard it
forever knew it from the get
I'm like documentaries are the only
thing I like the only thing I could sue
yeah and like I laughed now that I've
gotten in a place like my whole life now
that I'm in a place where maybe I can be
in some of them I always laugh because
I'm like man I'm always gonna deliver
for documentaries like filmmakers
because like I'm so deep in it that like
when I'm on I'm like I know what I got
to give them
[Music]
that's crazy right i slayed that blue
tag video I know so much more about
stuff than I think people realize yeah
so fashio google it that's why I'm
scratching my back a lot it's called
fashion you know what fashion is does
anybody know what that term means like
you know how they don't teach you
anything in school that actually matters
but like it would've made real sense
like teach people how to do taxes that's
kind of that's how I feel about fashio
it will literally change your life if
you've got the same issues I've had my
entire back and life and mobility and
quality of life as I've exploded now
that I'm breaking down my fashio America
the world you need to break down your
[ __ ] faccia if you have it everyone's
livin by different things like like the
thought that I would care like I don't
even know the things that people care
about like like I if you if you told me
what country clubs are better than what
I would like I'd start laughing around I
know nothing in a world where there's a
lot of them around here I don't need the
guy what sit by Bonnie Breyers AJ's
right okay that's one let me keep going
here and my brother isn't one in
Larchmont it's a golf club i don't know
that and i you know what i like i like
that i don't know certain things like i
really don't know which Silvo house or
core club like i don't even know like
i'm so in my own head so if I roll into
something people just get crazy it's
really funny
but it's my show once I come out
different Bank